allez c'est parti
[Musique]
et partir en laponie il va falloir
gagner des jeux et aujourd'hui il y aura
des jeux voilà qui compteront et on aura
des points pour partir en laponie dès
aujourd'hui c'est une qualification
directe qui se joue pour la la vous
allez faire le tour des cadeaux courir
il y à des hôtes derrière le père noël
va vous verser quelque chose sur la tête
alors si vous avez la poudre d'or ça
veut dire que vous partez en laponie
[Rires]
vas-y père noël vas-y attention à la
baisse non
[Applaudissements]
ça n'est pas bon
[Rires]
changer c'est plus ce que c'était
grâce à sa mère c'est parti alors ça
dépasse et la poudre de cacao n'est pas
ça
joe truc vous êtes éliminé bernard du
couscous ça s'écoute plus cette affaire
et instructif
ça va aller benjamin castaldi
vous avez toujours eu de la chance au
jeu toujours toujours là tout attention
5 4 3 2
[Applaudissements]
la police bravo maza maracas talent du
rouble est qualifié pour la polynésie
on est content laisser regarder la tête
de leurs mots et je l'avais proposé
voilà big ben voila voila les chefs
[Musique]